hello and welcome back to the corridor
cast this podcast has officially become
a podcast where we sit around drink some
of our favorite beer and talk about
things that interest us so welcome back
I'm glad you guys are here at the table
today we've got Ren hey hasn't gone
we've got Nico hi we've got Sam I'm Sam
and you've got Jake that's me
hi hi Wow Nico you look sleepy
why I don't know you just do the whole
day shooting that way
shooting matrix bb's yeah the question
was this Anton can take it out of you
can you dodge a bullet the way neo does
the matrix we like whips himself back
and does limbo and the bullets fly by it
turns out the answer is yes it's very
easy to dodge bullets like that we
thought we're getting it shot up the
whole time Wow I know these got a little
kick anyways it's very easy spoilers
turns out I can totally dodge bullets
and I am the one Wow yeah you can check
out the video note by the way oxygen
yelling Trinity's name it'll be out
probably the same day as this podcast oh
yeah yeah head on over to note if you
guys haven't seen that episode already
yeah open the podcast we will talk about
that it's got no problem talking about
that but this isn't the forum for so can
I just say that these are like the
biggest beer cans I've ever seen
by the way there are 25 ounces and yes
and today's sponsor our lovely sponsor
is not the beer that we're drinking it
is storey blocks you guys thank you
story bucks for sponsoring this video
it's your one-stop shop for all your
video asset needs if you guys need a
stock video asset consider story box
more on them later
right just big thanks and
it's not the beer I know that's
unfortunate we wish that it was the beer
but I'm happy to have any sponsor so
thanks sorry blocks yeah sure cheers the
story block Cheers with the beer Sears
to story is used story blocks on so many
videos at this point like countless
videos hundreds millions even well
that's why there that's why they're our
sponsor yeah can you imagine going out
and just taking shots and hoping that
someday somebody will find that one shot
useful I do that actually really
frequently
that's how Sam put us down payment on
his house little do we know every
evening Jake wearing a master chief
costume and Nico wearing like a filter
random shop are you ok well I did I did
get in the under suit for the Master
Chief for the Ironman thing we just did
those days are behind you well I'm
willing to do it for Squarespace cuz
they're great but anyway that suit has
seen some weather it has some internal
whether it's the actual one day we're
filming Outsiders for game heroes versus
comic book heroes that yeah ends first
video the he directly on Channel Jake
was Master Chief of course that's five
years ago so there's a leather suit that
you wear underneath this the the armor
it's like a solid leather suit it's
plastic it's waterproof it's a body body
glow he's trucking along and he's like I
can't eat a quick break and right ok and
he goes out to the side take his boots
off and He pours out a cup of water from
each boot and that was all sweat that
are collected in the leather suit and
then ran all the way down his legs and
out the ankles
it's the grossest thing I've ever seen
put that suit on for an hour to film
that thing yesterday or two days ago and
the shirt that I had on was completely
soaked also a/c was broken it was it was
as if somebody had thrown it into a
bathtub full of water and then pulled it
out and just
threw it back on my shoulder that really
reminds me of my mascot days have I told
you guys I've told you guys that my
mascot stories I was a mascot in college
yeah yeah okay so it's like what's more
this is for University of Portland and
there's ass mascot called Wally Pilate
he basically looked like a giant fake
version of Jay Leno with this huge
silicone head in this huge butt chin so
like we'd be dancing around I had one of
my best friends and I we would trade off
at halftime on basketball games and
you'd always try to change into the suit
as fast as you could because they were
soaking wet and he wanted to get in
before the sweat cooled off sweat is
significantly worse than warm sweats oh
yeah anyway we ended up doing really
good and meanwhile sweats pouring down
your head and just filling up that butt
chin so it's like you have this
reservoir yeah that's actually me on the
right there that is legitimately me
Christian what's this guy's called Wally
pilot can you pull up walle wallet pilot
he was a very very creepy looking mascot
back in the day or something yeah so I
ended up having so much sweat in this
chin and that are any of these you read
yeah probably several of those that's
yeah it's probably me there at the top
they they since redesigned him and you
can see on the top right there that's
the redesign I've never said that was
after I graduated anyway we storm the
the Court after we want a big important
basketball game in this his name is Luke
Sigma and he grabbed me in a bear hug
and then shook me like a salt shaker
just up and down and meanwhile all that
sweat that had accumulated from both my
friend and I over the course of this two
or three hour game I was like and if
anyone ever has any video of that game
he could see like I'm all excited with
everyone else as we storm the court and
then I get shaking up and down I just
slowly walk off the court not caring
about any more celebrations I'm elated
into the chin sweat oh yeah there was
there's some pretty awful sweaty days in
that suit especially when my friend left
it in his trunk all weekend in the Sun
and just bakes and we had to get in it
yes gross okay
couple things that have been going on
since we last chatted so uh I found a
couple things now this video came out a
while ago but I saw it for the first
time and maybe you guys haven't seen it
yet did you know that the Boston
Dynamics dog spot did you know the UI
Union you know the design right oh yeah
this little spot yeah he can now haul
trucks yeah look at this so in this
video just is it a group of spots or yes
it's like it's like Rudolph and the 12
Santa's reindeer and they're all
harnessed up and they're hauling
basically a a moving truck wow they
built a lot of them yeah oh yeah there's
like one two three four five six seven
eight well I'd heard that start selling
them soon Dasher dancer Prancer vixen
Blitzen
there's 10 drinking a blue semi-truck
it's just awesome dynamics on it oh yeah
food for thought for the next video yeah
I know right dude Boston Dynamics three
yeah already shut the second one yeah
how's that going Sam oh great it's
awesome
and it's gonna be way cooler and
creepier than the first one maybe or how
well the robot has a gun robot has a gun
the entire time and it's kind of like
the first one was like hey it's funny
cuz its Boston Dynamics and then we read
the comments or it and everyone was like
wow this is kind of weird and scary and
you shouldn't beat up robots it's cruel
and we're like oh yeah let's be real
those are military developments yeah
exactly and that's the thing as I was
because the first video was very well
received by the guys at Boston Dynamics
yeah you know they liked it and so we're
like oh man I hope we really don't make
them angry by doing this but that's like
yeah you're right they do they're gonna
they're gonna love it they're gonna love
it yeah Boston Dynamics is owned by
Softbank which is a Korean robotics
company speaking of other things in
robotics Ren I'm glad you mentioned it
Oh bot yeah researchers this just in
guys researchers in Japan have made a
robotic tail for humans wait what yeah
is this what they used on the cactus our
researchers from the
he di University in Japan have created a
robotic tail for humans that's designed
to assist in balance maintenance known
as arc this is a biometric wearable
robot oil really offset imbalance is
produced by move oh that's pretty cool
okay I'm actually really intrigued
because that's not a thing hey I want to
be a cat girl it's like hey this is
actually that's really neat oh yeah and
it provides like touch stimulation
haptic feedback to the wearer touch
simulation you know like you know like
sensory I know you touch a cat's tail I
understand tell you it's like an
infomercial yeah we're watching a little
video right now just for those he's not
watching on the video behind the stairs
it's like an infomercial it shows a guy
like stumbling up the stairs when Amazon
package like unlike the human body so a
vertebrate animals rely on their tail
passively for balance yeah I already
have pretty decent balance but I can see
myself having way better balance if I
had a tail so what yeah for a second it
looked like those on the front Sam so
it's really interesting because it
functions it on its own and and it
offsets imbalances on its own
mm-hmm that's pretty sweet yeah I
totally wear that once so at least a try
oh do you think that they're gonna
incorporate these into like soldier
suits and stuff and I doubt it if
they've like nice at the end or
something she's done a mace at the end
oh yeah like a spike the ball yeah so
there's no better balance so there's me
they'll worry more weight so they
they've got like exoskeletons come in
they're way rather than yeah
XO tails I don't think there's a
military application for this one but
maybe ninjas me in the same sense
there's a military application for shoes
as in like it's you know they let you
walk you okay ninja you're comparing a
robotic tail tail hard words I do I
listen I think I think yeah ninjas would
really benefit from it because they
don't wear a lot more ninjas they have
to crouch and kneel and lean forwards
frequently but ninjas aren't a viable
military option
I know what this lets you do is it lets
you do the Naruto around with your arm
straight backwards because usually you
need your arms like counter the like you
know torque of your body swinging left
and right but now the tail can do that
so you just stay straight back from
maximum aerodynamic efficiency
that's very true you can lean forward
all the way and you can run right in
there like seriously the Naruto run it's
like you can only do it if you're
running at a certain velocity which is
counteracting like you know you from
falling forwards yeah and the average
human can't run as fast as it's required
to Newberry to run properly like an
eight or a magnitude yeah so this tail
is the only thing that's gonna that's
standing so that's why it was developed
yes we'll see no I'm glad this stuff is
being developed because oftentimes the
people who are actually developing this
stuff have no idea how it's gonna end up
being applied in in practice you know
base like like we created this new
technology and it's up to someone else
to actually figure out ways to use it
right that's where all research is about
and ultimately these guys built the tail
Boston Dynamics made Santa's reindeer
but they don't know what they're gonna
be used for yeah they should give the
dog the tail you can't be gonna get a
brand deal with Boston Dynamics to get a
dog that would no way would they give us
one hey probably those are probably
under six such strict they're selling
them they're selling out they're going
to start selling them soon they're lucky
like preorder them they're like two
grand I think right I don't think they
gotta see a price no probably that's it
and we've listed a price I don't know
they're probably a lot of money I would
I'm willing to bet they're probably
super you know how many they would have
to manufacture to get the price down to
two grand I don't know like there's a
youtuber making his own more dynamics
dog using open-source software and
hardware he's 3d printing all the parts
it's pretty cool I think it's called
like open dog project huh I forget the
youtubers name though you have some cool
videos are just long and nerdy Wow
losing money on research this one this
one
do these segues today by the way I know
I might say Guo's are fantastic today
but basically the question that I want
to ask is is the following something
that you think government spending
should actually be used for cuz it's a
pretty interesting thing so
take this and take this for what it's
worth here alphabets deep mind AI
research okay has lost has come at a
loss to alphabet each of the last three
years with five hundred with the
research program taking a five hundred
and seventy million dollar loss last
year now their their mission is to
create human-level AI okay and the
reason why it's so expensive is because
they have to hire expensive researchers
and data scientists without being able
to generate any significant revenue yeah
now they're also competing with Amazon
Apple Facebook they're all locked in
this expensive battle to create
human-like AI and with the goal that
these will eventually be self learning
and can transform industries and all the
stuff the good stuff that would come
with that so here's the thing for me
none nothing about this seems unusual
like it obviously makes sense yet they
are pouring tons and tons of money it's
because it's a bit of like a cold race
right now right a cold war race it's
like you know between Amazon Facebook
and Microsoft and alphabet aka Google
they're all you know whoever ends up
coming up with the very first like super
intelligence is gonna win okay but but
but but look look deep mind spent 483
million on around 700 employees that's
six hundred and ninety thousand dollars
per employee okay
and well they're always spending more
than that per wait is that how much they
actually on payroll they're paying each
of their technicians 690 grand I
wouldn't be surprised because those
engineers are in such huge demand of
being like coached by all these other
companies they all want these and people
researchers I guess it's possible it's
like I mean this seems like normal
supply and demand to me well as
proximate executives are making like
five million probably yeah million and
there's like probably a lot like every
other engineers probably making like
three to four hundred grand I don't know
I have I have a few friends who work at
Google and they they they make Bank
mm-hmm so like just regular some of the
middle you singers do you think that I
mean this is a perfect
example of a private industry trying to
develop the next layer of their
technology that will eventually turn
around and benefit basically every
modern industry and actually I am
thinking about something for a long time
here and you just opened up that can of
beans okay
the algorithm doesn't work for you or
any user the algorithm always works for
the company so that AI is not going to
benefit any individual that AI is gonna
benefit the company the algorithm on
YouTube is not there to give you the
best viewing experience you can possibly
have that outdoors is there to give make
them the most money they possibly can
have or whatever other metric they go
yeah so but doesn't it make sense then
that they're gonna pour all that money
into it to benefit themselves just like
but you don't you don't think that
there's like benefits that other
industries and other companies will see
obviously there are I feel like we have
all benefited by proxy we by proxy from
this is the tricky thing you're kind of
right there are their benefits so we're
gonna see but I'm just the deeper we get
in this rabbit hole of like technology
the more I see that like these quote
unquote benefits are just as much being
marred by like their exploitation for
very specific things and they're
controlled by very specific groups or
specific goals it's just like it's like
I said earlier like the death of
virality there's no such thing as a
viral video anymore well once in a while
there is but not nearly to the tune it
used to be because every single network
that people shared their content on has
now locked it down so you can't share
the content out of the network so in
other words Kay you it's very very hard
to go viral off a platform because
Facebook doesn't let you post YouTube
videos you to doesn't let you post
Facebook videos Instagram doesn't let
you post tweets like you know they're
not gonna let you do that so yeah what
does that have to do with this what it
has to do with this is that cool
Google's developing a great AI and
they're going to use it for their
purposes and hopefully their purposes
are good and honest and lead to a
benefit for everybody but it could also
just as much lead to them using it to
manipulate things the way they want to
which is exactly how they're using
YouTube like this big blast of content
you have on YouTube right now is because
of what they are making to get
themselves more ad revenue yeah but I
mean okay obviously they're a for-profit
business so obviously they're not just
do anything for charity sake told at the
same time I don't think it's fair to
just say like well they're only gonna do
things that benefit them yes they're
gonna they're gonna they're gonna do
things that are aimed to benefit them
but I don't think but the way that they
benefit themselves as they've shown with
the entire Google suite as they shown
with YouTube Google services Google
Analytics there's other applications for
all of those services that yes benefit
them but also benefit all these other
businesses I mean our business wouldn't
exist if it were true if it wouldn't be
for in part for Google and like wasn't
the flip side of that this advancement
in AI wouldn't exist if Google wasn't
investing billions of dollars into it
yes I would make it instead but I think
just it's a cautionary tale it brings up
the whole like thing with copyright you
know it's like copyrights been what
extended to the death of the artist plus
70 years it's just we have to make sure
that patent law and Technology law has
expirations
appropriate expirations on things so
that at a certain point stuff that's
been created has been profited from
people see the return on their
investment and then finally everybody
else gets the profit from it as well
well of course but that's why I'm
suggesting like maybe this is the
perfect thing for for governmental
assistance in the sense of like
subsidies to support this kind of
research would that be fair to I don't
know
I'm not I'm really one to not have
government assistance and subsidies for
things but I don't think it needs it
yeah I mean I well I mean they did the
same thing with like the railroads and
like humanity sure but things highway
systems things that service topic though
but yeah races yeah happening regardless
of any assistance from the government
like that is gonna cuz these these
companies Facebook etc they want to be
on top of the AI game and they're gonna
you know spend as much money as they
need to to get there I don't think the
subsidies will help that you know
railroads for instance like without the
subsidies the railroads probably
wouldn't have gotten off the ground well
yeah right exactly because I mean
they're they're putting the money in
already without subsidy subsidies I feel
like are great for things that everyone
collectively knows we need to deal with
but understand that there's not like a
like a proper market value to make it
you know the entire
and to allow capitalism to do like that
you know run its natural course right we
we you know we talked about this to was
like the whole thing with China in the
US and blah blah yeah you know so I mean
personally I think the subsidies are
kind of in the environmental territory
right now if anything
well of course yes no one seems to want
to handle that too much but the I think
is pretty sweet
but hmm yeah dude yeah I've always seen
everything about AI and whatnot as like
an inevitable end like it is heading
that way whether we want it to or not
there's no reason to assist it further
by the government the government's much
better off in my opinion subsidizing or
assisting in other efforts like the
Noah's prom adding climate change using
all that stuff renewable energy like
maybe focus in that area I think that'd
be alright you guys are familiar with
the term the singularity when it comes
to technology right I mean the gray goo
[Laughter]
yeah synchros directly inspired by Ray
Kurzweil singularity theory but
generally the idea with the singularity
and there's different theories that are
put forth but singularity when it comes
to black holes is a point where all
physics break down and you can no longer
predict things based on normal physical
yeah theorems and formulas the center of
a black hole essentially exactly and
then you also have the event horizon or
once you cross the event horizon there's
no going back because the gravity is too
strong would you leave you know
something just coming out of a black
hole the other day
technically stuff does come out of black
holes it's called Hawking radiation but
it's very very tiny because they just I
just read an article about something
some some form of light coming out of a
bike I believe Hawking radiation is also
when you have positrons and negatron sir
like antimatter and pazzo matter
splitting apart then one of them gets
stuck in the hole and the other one is
that that's what in a reef history of
time that's no I I don't think you're
wrong at all okay I was just like oh man
I like the words you're saying yeah I
just read this the other day nasa sees
for the first time ever something coming
out of a black hole but it wasn't the
first time there's been the radiation
black holes before well what is it what
did they see it's in a brief history of
time Stephen Hawking writes about how
you know you have mattering of
antimatter and the radiation is
basically like one half of that split
being sucked into the hole while the
other half doesn't get sucked in yes the
radiation yeah I know more about it
I got about through the first third of
it yeah
anyways that's probably a really rough
awful explanation and you are wrong do
you think it's read it in like his voice
anyways the whole point of singularity
is that his original voice so we're
crossing an event horizon here which is
machine learning and you hit this point
where when machine learning can work on
machine learning and make machine
learning better to make a better machine
learning algorithm to improve machine
learning oh when we hit this exponential
curve and it goes up and that's useless
at event horizon there's no lose control
yes this is that's specifically what
Elon Musk refers to when he says opening
like the genie out of the bottle like
it's like no it's summoning the demon
I think this specific one was like oh
yeah they like the people someone in the
demon we're pretty sure they could
control the demon but you know yeah but
so this happens you cross the event
horizon technologically speaking with AI
where AI itself starts improving things
better than humans can and so your
entire reliant on AI which can also be a
tool you don't fully understand how it
functions internally it's like how I
don't understand how our brains
necessarily function internally and it
goes and goes and goes and you reach the
technological singularity where all
understanding of societal norms and
human progression break down and you're
no longer able to use your anthropology
and historical theories to predict
things because some of the AI is taken
over in the entire concept of how life
functions is different so that's the
technological singularity entire concept
of how life functions no sorry nothing
like how like life biological functions
how society functions basically how like
economics and society and history and
anthropology and like all these other
things that I see yeah markets and write
and industry say oh currency is going to
fluctuate because there's a big you know
frost that killed the wheat you know
yields over in Siberia like you know
that doesn't apply anymore
none of those theories apply anymore it
would happen in that scenario like if if
an AI was in control of the markets and
that did happen
well imagine there's no more markets
imagine there's no more software
programming
imagine that imagine if somebody thrust
into a situation where all things that
like we're not that far from like
needing to go out and like scrounge for
berries and bushes still like people
seem to think that we're like oh we're
all so nice it's like four I see people
on the street and that are on drugs and
stuff and I'm like I'm three bad
decisions away from that yeah
scrounging for berries it's like four I
think if an AI was to exist on that
level like we're talking about genie out
of the bottle I don't think it's a
singular AI well I think it's that it's
everything is suddenly a I designed and
something everything is better with AI
you know it's somebody control like how
thing even something would be
controlling it per se it's just like
imagine a isiliye starts just designing
and predicting everything and I think
obviously I think it would be completely
positive until it finds an energy source
that's off planet
that's better than Earth and so
basically it would probably it's an AI
is best interest is to keep humans
working and like alive and happy and
helping it because the moment we stop
like I think AI will reach it it's it's
it's already clear right now we like the
AI and in computer learning is better
than what it can accomplish in the
physical world as far as like I you know
the great example is like you hire a
plumber to fix like some some stuff in
your house having a robot that is able
to come to your house and like do all
that that like you know it's very
specific small things like that you know
that's really hard for something you
know that's robotic or
computer-controlled to accomplish and so
it will it would heavily heavily rely
humans to on on humans to interact with
the physical world and so that's why it
would actually be really symbiotic in it
I really I really honestly believe that
there's so many effed up scenarios that
could result from that but there's a lot
of great scenarios it basically would be
a symbiotic thing with people where it's
like hey we're gonna help basically
control thinking for the globe while
everyone else gets to live they're like
physical pastoral like lifestyle where
you don't have to worry about technology
you know yeah and and you don't have to
worry about that stuff and basically
just just work on some cool space probes
for us the the computer hivemind
so that way we can explore space
properly and
more than that yeah yeah but in all
likelihood in that scenario you don't
need nearly as many humans as are around
today true also I believe perhaps I can
remember if we've already lost Lisa sure
sure but you know whatever to research
creates friction no yeah I'm not I'm not
trying to like change grades friction
everyone knows that I'm just saying like
Wow oh wait that's interesting yet we
don't need seven billion people as it is
right now but as are you suggesting we
like talking the herd or something I
don't really have control down this road
you know podcast in a row or we've
talked extensively about AI it's cool
it's really sweet you're like wow all of
my dreams in sci-fi like imaginary
worlds I'm being realized you know that
scene in the third Matrix where he meets
the architect yeah
Olin okay sorry what an obscure
reference but my point is at the at the
a at one of the ends of those roads Sam
is a situational situation where there's
only like where there's only like a few
people and they're just created like in
an AI lab - how to do research and and
and things that the AI do but that's if
you're like really pessimistic hey you
guys want auxins come here right here we
go guys welcome to the conspiracy theory
podcast hot off the presses here we go
ready go go all right I'm starting with
this one how long do you think until
some machine or AI is classified as a
life form for months months whose class
mister who's doing the classifying
United States Guard substance of the pot
a large swath of the population
considers a 1200 that's that's like
tomorrow a swath large to get everything
you read on Twitter and the majority of
opinions that you read on Twitter are
not the majority of opinions of people
on the planet so we need to separate
that how about how about the United
States Supreme Court mmm
okay and I don't mean like yeah
logically I find that the Supreme Court
the United States is something I can
respect something that's tangible yes
you're talking about with the winds of
emotion it's kind of up to perception
like I'm not saying like wait it's like
oh it has cells therefore it's alive I'm
more than saying like when you look at
something you say that's alive okay but
are you talking about consciousness or
like actual like breathing living I
would say because like I feel like we're
far closer to creating a conscious mind
that only lives in a computer but is
real and has memories and cultures and
emotions yeah that gosh I mean see I
don't mean like biological I mean like I
don't know what the term for this would
be but yeah you know a hundred years
effectively like a oh I'm an empathetic
understanding with the being where you
feel like it's alive and you identify
with it as being like a mental
understanding about being a lot you know
biologically it it doesn't have DNA and
it doesn't have sales like you know it
doesn't follow the biological definition
so the Boston Dynamics video we did were
Wiz Khalifa's like that's cruel you know
ok cruel it's a robot is throwing a
toaster cruel because like you know if
he thinks this robot has emotions or is
thinking or anything you can say the
word cruel you know it's like so I argue
that I think he said it like yo that's
cruel I know but you know not like
that's cruel but what I'm getting at is
that like by that simple the simple
definition is projecting you know we're
thinking and feeling about this
inanimate object I think that currently
it is happening right now
right I mean just the anthropomorphic
form or the sizing of it's like it's
human nature but yeah but it's gonna be
a but it's not a big deal but like look
at animal life you know you look at
things from like a bird or like a worm
or a bug and then you look at like a
whale and an elephant and these life
forms that have like really complex like
like just brains and they think dolphins
and so it's like that's like saying if
if you think a you know a worm is is
like a thinking being and then you turn
to a dolphin it's like no they're
totally on different levels as far as
complexity and emotions and thought yeah
and things like that and so it's a
sliding scale I think and it really it
really ultimately
just the the the beholders perception
you know like that bats and then that's
why I'm saying it's happening right now
because people were looking at robots
and going hey I feel bad for that robot
it's don't mess with it you know and and
that's that's like the lowest level
that's like seeing a bug that's helpless
and someone's like don't step on it
right I don't know I feel like it's a
little different for our Boston Dynamics
video because it was an actual like
person thing like it's obviously not a
human but it's acting like a human I
mean it was literally clear we're
beating up on this human thing we're
able to project our own emotions onto it
be like oh man if I was that robot but
all the people who didn't see the game
yes the robot fights back in that video
annoyed it actually exudes their million
there you go well so where do you think
this comes from in the human psyche do
you think that this feeling of hey you
shouldn't even at the lowest level you
shouldn't squash that bug kick that
robot do you think that comes from this
sort of like communal bonding and
dependence that humanity has totally
comes from a fear of entropy in our
desire to bring order to chaos well
death is chaos and entropy and life as
it was a more biological reason for it
yeah I think it's because because humans
are inherently reliant upon one another
to survive
I'd agree and so we've developed over
time this biological understanding that
if something is being harmed its it
could might not be good for us okay
fear of chaos on the right thing yeah
it's an instinctual decision that like
we want allies over enemies basically
and regardless of where they live you
know in the animal kingdom or what kind
of person they are yeah so I'm gonna
follow up ghosts time to go deeper guys
conspiracy theory time wait Niko hold
that thought you're already 21 and hey
guys and welcome to the sponsorship
segment of this video where I tell you
about today's awesome sponsor story box
now if you don't know story box is a
Members Only one-stop shop for all your
stock video needs why is that awesome
well first and foremost they offer on
limited downloads for as long as you
have a membership so if you're a video
editor or a creator and you need b-roll
you need After Effects templates you
need motion backgrounds story box is the
one-stop shop for you now also
everything that they have on their site
is royalty free and it's studio quality
so you never have to worry about it not
working or not being able to use it for
particular purposes you just have a
membership and anytime you need
something simple you just go on there
you grab the asset that you need and you
put it in the video it works
real great we use it here all the time
and I gotta say it's a lot easier than
trying to go out and get stuff on our
own so if you guys are interested all
you have to do is go to story box comm
slash corridor cast and you can check
out more information and you can sign up
and like I said unlimited downloads
studio quality one-stop shop for all
your stock video needs so go on and
check out story box at story box comm
slash corridor cast we'd be glad if you
did they'd be glad if you did and oh
yeah you'd be glad if you did so back to
the podcast okay
so time to go deeper down the conspiracy
theory hole we're talking about
artificial life do you guys think guys
wow you guys if you guys are listening
all the inventors cuddled up I want them
cuddles if a computer what part of the
computers the lungs
[Laughter]
do you guys think that scientists have
created a cell in a lab from inanimate
materials but they haven't said anything
yet are you talking about a fabricating
life advocating life move I don't think
so I my hunch is no I think they've
taken the I'm sure they're trying oh I'm
sure they're trying I'm sure they're
working on it pretty hard but I don't
think they've succeeded yet yeah it's
it's really that is the same as the
creating of fire by Moses but okay so
the creating life aspect of that yeah
but they are working on like basically
3d printing and not 3d pranks
specifically but like growing organs and
whatnot is that you're starting with
you're already starting with living
cells right I'm talking about taking
like okay I got my ribonucleic acid and
I got my I'm sorry that's about as far
as my terminology isn't that RNA isn't
that just like your the alternative DNA
like the middle ground I don't know yeah
my C's and my cheese maze and I got my
other suit man I got my serotonins my
dopamine's and I got my water and my
saline and I got I got all the different
things I need I got my lipids my fatty
acids my amino acids which are all just
building like basically giant organs
already based off of smaller molecules
yeah those are basically different
chemicals that's right right oh yeah and
I stir them together and I get a cell I
mean that's like creating fire it's the
world's most advanced stirring so I'm
stirring well I mean stirring with a
blueprint made out of DNA so like let's
say the planets been around for like for
in some change billion years okay so
like how many billions back is that it
was the first living living cell it's
four point like so one seven I guess
that's what I think really the question
how many Siri when did life begin on
earth Oh life are you talking about okay
hold that's way different nico life has
only been around for like one to two
billion years and that existed for the
longest time is just like tiny little
cells these little things like not even
algae algae was super advanced well
that's what that's I think the answer
though is like how how likelihood like
how likely do you
it's that scientists have been able to
compress those billions of years of
random chance in a lab setting 3.5
billion years ago I called it that life
start early cells so basically
scientists have 100 days to make life
years of life in hundred days I don't
know I don't think life really started
that started pretty quick which makes me
wonder if life is actually way more
prevalent than well because that like
Earth is only like four four and a half
billion years old yeah let's let's walk
this let's walk this back a series earth
molti go it was the universe you go all
1300 all that you can happen where it
was like it was like hey what's wrong
all that you need to create life is like
a couple elements right a couple
fundamental elements you got your
proteins
you got your sorry you got here I don't
know anything about this it just seems
like there's probably a couple
fundamental chemicals and things like
that but that seem to be identified as
as core to this Ryan millions of years
of chance of course mm-hmm
so I mean you're still talking about
from the time that the earth was created
assuming the math is correct 4.5 is
checked 4.5 that's earth billion years
before life in the smallest most menu of
form was created that's up one be just
be random sludge being struck by
lightning in a puddle like I don't know
how yeah but like you had that you had
the heat element from the from all this
stuff colliding in space earth was very
hot come combine with like all of the
chemicals that are there it seems like I
mean I don't know but it seems like it
well my point being is if the earth
could do it in a billion years just
accidentally I kind of feel like at this
point so we may have done it in the lab
intentionally or maybe it was an AI from
the future that went back in time it's
gonna be it but what do you think that
would do to society to find out that
somebody created a cell from literally
just from taking the ingredients and put
them together and I mean that wouldn't
be a battle for science and medicine do
you think that just cause every church
to come collapsing down at that point
are like no no and now people wouldn't
care
churches still exist even though all of
this science stuff the whole universe is
like mapped out yeah I mean yeah it's
very yeah times a thing like what's
beyond the universe you know that's yeah
I never thought it would and this is
this is very like a very much of a
rebellious opinion but I never thought
that science and church
honestly were that much different I just
thought Church was a way of explaining
science differently
I think that's see like healthy mindset
about Church that's what it's always
seemed like yeah growing up growing up
when people are like yeah there was Adam
and Eve and there was the seven days and
I was like that's just a way of someone
who existed thousands of years ago
writing down what we now know in their
own interpretation oh yeah I mean I
think that's the kind of common sense
healthy way like this I'm gonna go to
limb here I'm gonna say like you know
church has always seemed like it's more
appropriate to understanding the human
condition than actually explaining
questions about the universe yeah yeah
well I think like once you start like if
you if you chop off the first seven or
eight days or so you know that are
described in the Bible yes we start on
day eight all right I mean I'm pretty
cool with it to be honest okay well I'll
read you some passages that are a bit
questionable but it makes more
entertaining yeah that's how others yeah
it's like I I never understood the
people who were like no actually there's
no such thing as dinosaur bones those
are fake like what I don't understand
why this isn't congruent with everything
else yeah why do I have to be so hard on
these Dino bones yeah like there's still
plenty of like really great things
anyway
remember that flat earth documentary on
Netflix oh yeah is there no I do not
remember it not not the Logan Paul one
that we worked on Netflix yeah no I
didn't watch it I heard about it was
alright so a character study then it was
like about anything else um like these
sad men are about to have their minds
blown
Jen was talking to me and he pointed out
something that he was really
disappointed that the documentary
glossed over which is there's a big
tie-in to like fundamental Christianity
and flat earthers what's the
fundamentalists that give Christianity a
bad name man yeah I mean I think most of
anything tend to give anything yeah
that's true they really take the fun out
of it they do they take the fundamental
ISM sorry that's the swear word that's
it explicit audio guys they really do it
really ruin it for everyone else cuz at
anytime anyone wants to make a critical
argument and say Christianity is bad for
the world all they do is point to the
crazy fundamentalists who don't accept
science or the Crusades when it does
have real value that we though can wait
wait wait wait wait wait who's pointing
to the Crusades still people all the
time religion it's the cause for all the
world's Wars look at the Crusades so you
know I really have a problem I think the
first thing anyone says I'm for several
eight hundred years ago yes like five
hundred you know it really burns my
biscuits that's the charter of the
forest from like the year 1300 do you
know sounds like little do you know that
those events helped shape helped shape
the environment that you live in today
in ways and ways and means that you
might never know Wow mmm-hmm Wow
so they speaking of shaping history and
shaping the future here's a real thing
that's going on this is my great another
great transition presented by me have
you guys heard about what's going on in
Hong Kong oh yeah yeah I love it I mean
I try and understand it but I mean I
don't love not doing a good job here's
here's a quick summary prepared to die
Hong Kong protesters embrace hardcore
tactics challenging Beijing here's
here's a summary in June so first and
foremost the thing that you need to
understand about Kong Kong is it was
part of the British Empire until 1997
I've been to Hong Kong aw stupid cool
yeah I love the city so in 1997 along
the Seine please got a passport along I
tell anyone the same about that's about
the same amount of time that the United
States was like hey let's give back the
Panama Canal this thing that we built
anyway I
go on but Panama have to do with home
sorry it was around the same time and
I'm sitting like the the geopolitical
ecosystem was like let's it's true
anyways just 99 Crusades UK gives back
Hong Kong to mainland China right okay
but there was a bunch of basically Hong
Kong was this huge financial center
still is today that was developed and
established through basically you know
Western financial practices and Western
laws regarding things like individual
freedoms and things like that yeah and
so when they gave it back they're like
well we're not just gonna give you to
the Communist it's like we're gonna
establish a dual Constitution one
country system and look at where at
least where the where the Hong Kong City
has a separate government and a separate
Constitution that's separate from
mainland China now this Constitution
protects like individual freedoms and it
protects like certain financial laws
that are different in Hong Kong that
they are in China and this basically
this agreement was supposed to go on for
50 years and over the last 20 mm-hmm the
surprise surprise the central government
of China has started to erode right a
lot of these rights China's not too into
that right and so all of this began in
June when the government of Hong Kong
basically tried to pass an extradition
bill that would allow for Hong Kong
citizens who are under that Constitution
to be sent to mainland China for crimes
and dirty management it's dirty its
dirty and so everyone that's a one-way
trip yeah and everyone that hong kong
was like we're not gonna agree to this
we we have the Hong Kong's we have a
rich world freedoms we have it's true
though it is serious yeah and so they so
they had all these protests and then
basically for fear in part for fear of
like what the mainland government would
do after the fact it's caused the
protestors to become hardened and and
more emboldened into their position to
try to like push off these this years of
of like encroaching encroachment and
unrest that has been slowly like seeping
in under the surface of the Hong Kong
system and so now it basically is it's a
direct threat to the Chinese central
government it is the Chinese central
government came out
imagine if the United States government
said this in a statement this is what
they told the protesters in Hong Kong
last week oh wait that's repaired he
said oh yes I said we would like to make
it very clear to the very small group of
unscrupulous and violent criminals and
the dirty forces behind them those who
play with fire will perish by it Wow as
for their punishment declara SH and as
for their punishment it's only a matter
of time don't misjudge the situation and
mistake our restraint for weakness and
don't ever underestimate the resolve and
strength of the central government Wow
yes which is exactly why everyone is
protesting yes that's great saying we're
going to take you over whether you like
it or not this is crazy this is the
actions housing there you know like a
misstep honestly today like put other
properties like that straight up
everyone or arrogance because they know
I can't get their way this is like the
the ultimate story of like 21st century
like just just just just like rebellion
and freedom and like everything
everything people worry about happening
here yeah it's like crazy like everyone
in the United States you know when we're
talking about all our politics over here
it's like oh you know oh my gosh they're
gonna take over and they're gonna take
our guns and stuff like that it's like
dude this is actually happening this is
the epitome of all those issues that's
why I think I wanted to bring this up
because it's it's this is a real version
of what people like to complain about
here yeah but actually happened hey
Christian pull up drone footage Racing
drone footage of the Hong Kong protests
there's some really really awesome
flights of like racing drones over the
the crowds of people protesting in Hong
Kong it's really awesome so okay
continue the the the Chinese government
keeps saying that the CIA is involved
with this which they probably are well
they're probably like and aiding right
and I mean but I mean but they're
putting of course that's a good thing
because the central government clearly
wants to take away the freedoms of the P
in Hong Kong search team black sheep but
this is a crazy situation you guys and
and this is yeah I don't think it's
talked about going like oh god yeah for
like one tenth of the computer one photo
came out to these million people are at
this one look at this one don't crash it
is a smaller drone so it's not gonna
hurt alright everyone thanks everyone
who is listening make sure you do pull
up this video if you uh if you have a
moment it's team black sheeps drone over
Hong Kong protest team black sheep is
like the og like FPV this is stunning
this is I read articles and seen photos
from this but this video is already
surpassing and making a stronger impact
with me than anything I've seen
everywhere are people Hong Kong is a
racing drone flying over just swabs and
swaths of people in Hong Kong grits of
thousands most likely yeah also diving
buildings it's like I'm getting all this
journalistic info but I'm having fun and
there's an interesting thing that's
going on here that that happens all the
time and and the UK agreed with the
central government of China and they
said basically okay guys everyone in
Hong Kong you're put on notice you've
got 50 years they sign this treaty and
in 1997 it's supposed to go to 20 47 oh
geez and that's there's a there's an
interesting parallel that can be drawn
at the origin of the United States with
the with the issue of slavery because
basically everyone knew it was like hey
this isn't gonna last but we're not
gonna do it we're not gonna deal with
this now because it's gonna destroy
countries and sure enough 80 years later
there's a huge war fought over it hmm
and the I mean you're seeing the seeds
of something similar being sown here yes
because obviously people want individual
freedoms no one in Hong Kong will ever
go back to what they're offering in
mainland oh no never never
yeah they've all been granted like the
independence
guess what the everyone in Hong Kong is
upset by all the people from mainland
China that invade into Hong Kong to like
purchase real estate and to like try to
live there and to try to become part of
that system because it's a much better
system do the Chinese purchasing real
estate is becoming a big problem in
Canada - they're just buying tons of
real estate and not putting any people
there so you're not getting any of the
benefits from actually having people in
those well that's a whole that's a whole
nother topic now which is the idea of
the real and real estate and investment
companies basically purchasing and
buying property for Airbnb usage which
is gutting Oh downtown areas of major
cities like in Iceland in a Reykjavik
really are think about 60% of properties
or so in Reykjavik right now or rental
arguably though that'll balance itself
crazy soon though yeah anyways it's
either sixty or forty percent either way
pretty right it's a small difference to
be saying Iike I said when the market
forces dictate that that's a necessary
thing at a certain point if like if the
rental the people are paying the prices
and renting those properties out it
shows that there's that much demand for
rental properties there is but it's it's
also just the idea of like how do you
deal with this from like an economy
slash city based perspective when you
have a city with pennilyn lives in it
kind of comes from overpopulation I feel
like overpopulation and global community
is something we all have to struggle
with tangent channel it's not
necessarily a bad thing just to get back
to this China thing thing what if you
guys were if you guys were there what
would you do I would think be cool to
try to put out a tear gas canister like
those guys were doing yeah I saw ways
all that video yeah where they I don't
even know what all they did they just
drunk driver a cone and into the
chemistry side of it and what's whele i
read up on that those tear gas canisters
are exothermic reactions okay so they
need to cool it down and what they do is
either like a traffic cone over and they
pour a bunch of water in it like not
necessary to smother it but to cool it
down it down to stop spinning off as
much tear gas right yeah dude I think
water lots and lots of water I think it
was just water yeah I saw someone with
like a like a water
we're jug or something in one of them -
here it is right here is this where they
come in with yeah okay so traffic goes
down a lot along the top of the traffic
hands so they're pouring it in traffic
and traffic cone so they're uh did you
just save the web page oh yeah yeah see
if we got the watercooler jug there and
now it's a little like they can handle
it and they like taking they get rid of
it I got tongs let's look at this oh
yeah crazy yes this is just doing worse
these guys really know their stuff it's
like this is a really organized like
anti right place I'm also surprised the
police haven't started using bullets
after the team's in solids yeah but so
after Tiananmen Square they just trade
up like pulverize people with tanks and
ground them into like meat yeah that's
why they're not doing that there's so
many because no Matt yeah like cuz
seriously it's like they'd started a
civil war instantly right they were
serving civil war and then people would
have to shoot like bombs I'm also really
proud of everyone in Hong Kong
protesting as a human I'm proud yeah
right it makes me feel really good to
see this happening because absolutely
man yeah I'm glad people are fighting
for the rights to be people to be a
person and not let anybody always tell
them like yes what you have to do and
how your government assignment role is
of Terezin yeah absolutely not to
convince her entire life into a social
media score score thing is actually in
today in China which is literally from
an episode of Black Mirror yes yes it's
like I remember first hearing that oh
yeah channels gonna do this I was like
man that's like that's crazy that's like
that black mirror up so and then eyes
actually saw that it's in effect today
like it's actually a thing now yeah I
just can't tell if it's like do they
really think it's for the betterment in
betterment of society or is it just kind
of like a like a pessimistic kind of
reaction to like controlling an unruly
popular you know I feel like I feel like
a bit of Chinese government culture is
that of everything's for the betterment
of the entire culture and society at the
expense of the individual I think it's a
little bit of that cultural mindset over
there yeah
not saying that every person believes
that but that's like kind of how the
government pajama Institute half-second
this China goes back very far into
history last a few years
97 or so China's history is 2,000 years
old arguably China is like the oldest
establish out like government is it no
they've been showing since before Greece
was evil I mean I read Sun Tzu
yeah and that's that's about 2,000 years
Risa's Kalev or sorry 1500 years old the
Arabic the Golden Age of a Arabia has
collapsed like but China's still
persisted it's true it's funny to see
how I mean I know this is somewhat
unrelated to the manufacturing and
middle class boom in that country but
it's funny to see how the country has
developed from an outside perspective
over the last 20 years yeah I mean I
remember when we were when we were
growing up when we were kids it was it
was very much like rural China was very
much a thing and then there was cities
with big manufacturing and as that
manufacturing base got bigger people
became more middle-class I mean remember
when things you say made in Japan on
them well they still do not as much
Japan used to be the home yeah I did you
mean in the 90s yeah yeah as a small
experiment the other day I did a little
kind of I scoured my living room with
Sarah and we're like all right let's
just just see what happens when we look
around how many items are gonna be made
in China and how many will be made just
generally elsewhere this out of it you
shoulda made a youtube video on this
this would have done really well well we
could still can guess what it was about
like one in ten basically what 10 was
what not Chinese Wow okay oh one intent
was not Chinese yes oh so 90% of
everything you own is Chinese yeah I
mean I mean if I dug deeper or one in my
garage maybe I'd find some different
things right behind you for well we I
mean I didn't like counting like guns
and stuff but I don't think they're made
in [ __ ] maybe they're made in Tennessee
anyway so it's an interesting thing he's
right that being said it's yeah it's
it's pretty scream yeah so a wild thing
that's happening right now in the real
world guy
check it out okay well it's getting
really hot in here yeah I think that
concludes this episode of the corridor
cast it's a good one yeah I think we've
learned we've all learned something so
intense I you know I feel like these
podcasts each time we hop in here it's a
little bit of like conspiracy theory a
little bit of topics
you know like news but like I feel like
headlines lately that we're kind of
reacting to everything is definitely
steering in a certain direction you know
what I mean don't you feel like it like
it feels like every week there is
something like really interesting
happening on a global scale with like
what we're doing with with China and
stuff like this and stuff with AI and
technology
yeah it's changing really fast and I
find it interesting how every time we
sit down to talk the discussion kind of
gravitates towards these topics well
here's the thing about here's the thing
about technological advancement it's
like not it's not only increasing at at
an accelerating rate the acceleration
itself is also accelerating so it's like
if you look back at the Year previous
worth of technological advancement your
natural like human instinct is to kind
of just extrapolate that linearly
forward one year but it's like it's
actually that's gonna be far less than
one year worth of progress yeah going
forward and that rate is also
significantly improving so it's like
next year that that rate will be quicker
and then year after that it's like
Edison why is that why every year seems
shorter than the last one no that's just
because we're getting old
oh we're getting old I know let's do it
let's get old hey thanks for watching
everyone this was fun to do and we're
gonna do more of them so stay tuned yep
probably next week hey also if you're a
new listener because we've already
talked about this much in the podcast we
haven't done one in a while but uh our
channels blew up this past couple months
here listen if you are one of the five
people out there who discovered the
coridor cast organically and don't know
that we have three other YouTube to
other YouTube channels oh I was gonna do
the other way as in like hey I you did
you just discover the coridor cast
because you just discovered
channels oh hey welcome just farmer I
wish you my best I hope you enjoy
everything you're listening to yeah it's
I am honored that you are listening to
our podcast that's why I was going to
say that also that makes more sense
boy if you found the podcast and you've
never you are in for a treat yes and the
topic of next week's discussion is other
things we've made how hot will you think
it's going to be here next time oh yeah
so this room there's no air conditioning
or ventilation and I don't quote on an
eric we need we need to bring a
thermometer in for the next one just 95
degrees i don't really sweat much not
humid listening like it's reading 84 i
think it's the humidity here it's 80
fighters i'm super sweaty i think we all
are
alright I'm gonna slide out of here boys